hallo herzlich willkommen zur dritten
folge von pimp my kitchen ich bin gerade
in einem kindergarten und zwar in
rockenhausen wir möchten in diesem
format pimp my kitchen menschen mit
einer neuen küche überraschen oder alte
küchen aufpumpen
[Musik]
hier seht ihr die liebe anna anna hat
uns vor einiger zeit kontaktiert und
zwar ist sie erzieherin im kindergarten
in rockenhausen der kindergarten wird
renoviert saniert er wird vergrößert es
gibt dann mehr räume für die kinder
einen größeren essbereich aber wie es
auch so oft immer ist im leben dann
reicht das geld nicht mehr aus für eine
schöne neue küche und die küche hier in
rockenhausen im kindergarten ist echt
richtig richtig altana hat mir videos
und fotos geschickt und hat den murat
wirklich öfter mal kontaktiert und wir
uns da kommen wenn man auch eine eigene
stiftung wir kommen vorbei wir schauen
uns die küche an und möchten euch neue
kindergarten küche einbauen
[Musik]
fans von mama schreiben
ich bin so gespannt wenn ich es nächstes
mal wieder da bin was du dann noch alles
kannst
hätte kann selbst schon alles
okay tschüss bis zum nächsten mal
[Musik]
im kindergarten sind momentan ungefähr
60 kinder im sommer sollen sogar bis zu
80 kinder werden und die werden von 20
erzieherinnen und erziehern betreut der
kindergarten ist so aufgebaut dass die
kinder auf vier gruppen aufgeteilt sind
und sie haben dort einfach verschiedene
essenspläne es gibt jeden tag ein
gesundes frühstück was ich ganz
besonders toll finde denn die kinder
dürfen damit werkeln sie dürfen
mitschneiden und das frühstück mit den
erzieherinnen gemeinsam vorbereiten und
gerade das finde ich super weil kinder
so lernen mit lebensmitteln umzugehen
und vor allem lernen sich gesunde
essgewohnheiten
sie lernen was es bedeutet lebensmittel
zubereiten wie man wertschätzen mit
ihnen umgeht und vor allem wie man sie
richtig verarbeitet und dementsprechend
daneben auch verzehrt die momentane
küche ist wie ihr sehen könnt ein
bisschen schwierig denn die küche ist
zum einen sehr klein aber das geben die
räumlichkeiten einfach nicht anders her
das heißt ich muss auch später in der
küche eben schauen wie ich zurechtkomme
und wie ich die küche aufbaue aber was
jetzt nicht nur den platzmangel betrifft
die küche ist einfach ganz ganz schlecht
ausgestattet die möbel sind schon
veraltet und es wurde einfach schon seit
über 40 jahren nichts in der küche
gemacht das bedeutet die möbel sind alle
sehr zusammen gewürfelt es viel stauraum
ohne ende und vor allem sind die
schränke und schubladen mittlerweile
muss man sagen sehr kaputt und die
elektrogeräte eigentlich kaum mehr
brauchbar was bei den elektrogeräten
auch noch der fall ist dass sie einfach
nicht mehr sicher sind vor allem nicht
für kleine kinderhände das bedeutet da
braucht auf jeden fall toll
elektrogeräte die dann in die küche
verbaut werden können sodass kinder eben
auch ganz bedenkenlos mit den
erzieherinnen und erziehern in der küche
arbeiten können die kirche soll aber
auch für die erzieherinnen später als
ort dienen an dem sie sich mal ausruhen
können wo sie sich tee und kaffee
zubereiten können oder eben auch ihr
eigenes mittagessen zubereiten können
einen großen raum zu planen und zu
bestücken ist natürlich ziemlich einfach
einen kleinen raum zu planen so dass er
zum einen gut aussieht aber auch
funktional und praktisch ist natürlich
ein bisschen schwieriger deswegen stehe
ich heute vor der herausforderung muss
natürlich diese kindergarten küche
planen sie ist noch nicht einmal zwei
meter breit das heißt es wirklich nur
ein meter 96 mal dafür natürlich in der
länge und bis länger und hat da ungefähr
drei meter 49 man muss natürlich die tür
aussparen die er auch einen einen großen
bogen macht das heißt da kann ich dann
auch keine möbel davor stellen und muss
so eben schauen dass alles in die küche
passt was eben auch rein soll ganz
wichtig an erster stelle ist für mich
der große kühlschrank das heißt da kommt
eine kühl gefrierkombination rein für
viele gesunde lebensmittel es kommt eine
herdplatte mit rein da habe ich auch
schon eine idee wie ich das gleiche
planen werde was auf jeden fall auch
nicht fehlen darf ganz viel stauraum in
der küche und natürlich auch eine große
arbeitsfläche damit die kinder und
erzieher dort eben auch schon arbeiten
können aber
[Musik]
damit die neue küche jetzt auch platz
findet muss natürlich erst mal die alte
küche raus
[Musik]
was können wir kurz helfen wer
hinter der tat steckt
ok
[Musik]
ich hab einfach aus der wand gerissen ja
ganz ehrlich ist schon raus rechte
scheiss kaltbach ich
jetzt habe ich mir geräte ausgesucht
fronten und eine arbeitsplatte für die
küche und sag ich mal meine kirchen
planung für die küche in rockenhausen
und zwar habe ich mir überlegt dass ich
auf jeden fall matte fronten verwende
und die fronten so ein bisschen
miteinander kombinieren farblich
natürlich ich nehme hier eine weiße
hölle front damit die küche einfach
offener und freundlicher wirkt und
kombiniere sie mit einer schönen grünen
front auf der rechten seite habe ich mir
gedacht dass man direkt in die küche
reinkommt und der große kühlschrank sich
dort befindet damit man auch direkt an
die gesunden zutaten kommt links daneben
auf augenhöhe ein bisschen erhöht habe
ich einen backofen ein kombigerät worin
man dampf gang aber auch eben backen
kann mit einem großen und einem kleinen
apotheker schrank wer dies schaffen dass
man zutaten schön verstauen kam für viel
stauraum sorgen kann und dass man an den
stauraum von beiden seiten kommt das
große waschbecken befindet sich dann an
der langen seite das kleine
handwaschbecken befindet sich direkt vor
der fensterfront denn ich habe die küche
einfach u förmig geplant so dass ich
hier noch ein bisschen platz und
stauraum gewinnen damit die küche nicht
so ganz zu gebaut wird wird noch ein
stollen regal von nobilia integriert da
schafft es nämlich dekorativ
lebensmittel oder auch und textilien zu
verstauen und ich schaffe dort auch den
platz für kräuter und vor allem frische
damit die küche nicht ganz zugebaut wird
habe ich die flächen links ein bisschen
tief mit kuerz gestaltet so dass die
schubladen etwas gekürzter sind und ich
zwei domino kochfelder integrieren kann
die werden gedreht und so hat man in der
küche trotzdem noch genug platz zum
vorbeilaufen geschirr tassen und gläser
verstehe ich dann oben in den hoch
schränken und damit dort ein bisschen
offener und schöner wirkt und vor allem
ein bisschen warmes licht mit reinkommt
integriere ich dort betrieben schränke
die eine indirekte beleuchtung mit b das
ganze kochgeschirr werkzeug und alle
utensilien die man in der küche
gebraucht werden dann in schubladen
verstaut so kommt nämlich auch jeder gut
ram und vor allem kann man alles
übersichtlich gestalten während ich mir
jetzt gedanken über die küchenplanung
mache bleibe ich natürlich immer mit
anheim austausch das heißt die kinder
erziehe und auch die eltern im
kindergarten werden mich immer updaten
und werden wir natürlich auch zeigen wie
weit sie schon sind ob die küche schon
komplett weg ist wann die wände verputzt
werden wie die fliesen aussehen und vor
allem auch natürlich waren die elektrik
reinkommt so dass ich perfekt planen
kann wann die küche eben angeliefert und
montiert wird
die arbeiten sind in vollem gange
die lucy und der friedrich sind schon
fleißig steckdosen an zu zeichnen
so sieht das macht es ja
so dass er auch die wand
[Musik]
schau mal was unsere küche passiert ist
die steckdosen sind verlegt
auch die rohre sind schon gelegt
jetzt wird schon beim alles kaputt und
dann wenden wir uns wieder bei dir schau
mal wieder ein großer meilenstein
geschafft die verputzarbeiten und heute
abgeschlossen auf die decke und verputzt
und
jetzt
[Musik]
so jetzt stehen wir nie und ich hier in
der kindergarten küche und hier wurde
schon einiges gemacht ihr habt die räume
das letzte mal gesehen und zwar war der
fließend da das ist ein unternehmen das
kommt hier aus der stadt aus hohenhausen
und die haben alles verputzt und die
fließen gespendet in den ganz ganz coole
aktion das hier rockenhausen wird nicht
zusammenhält und die ganzen mit all die
ganzen leute die hier wohnen und auch
friedrich wolfsgruber genau die haben
nämlich die ganze elektrik jemand ich
erwähnen dass werden
und was sollte es ganz ganz wichtig ist
dass wir zusammenhalten und wir haben
natürlich unseren ball volley kommst du
mal ganz kurz und zwar das ist der oli
der arbeit da auch hier und dann auch in
seiner freizeit hier
wenn oli komplett dunkel
und der oli du hast ja dann auch
gestrichen immer mitgeholfen du hast
noch was gemacht haben die fließen
hingelegt um das mal raus sprühten die
verbraucher umgelegt und ich finds halt
richtig cool dass die unternehmen die
privaten unternehmen hier in
rockenhausen uns dabei unterstützen hier
die küche wieder auf vordermann zu
bringen
die perfekte küche zu haben tausend dank
anna lehmann den fließen gaitán
friedrich wolfs gruppe wolfsgruber genau
wie du es verbindlich in ihrer freizeit
unterstützt haben keine kosten gespart
haben und an alle anderen auch an lang
und jetzt legen wir los
man halte ich habe noch nichts sicher
ist dass bei uns das krasse findet das
ist 80 jahre mensch auf der welt gibt
und dann schicken sie den fersen das ist
doch schlimm dass ich doch nicht sein
ich habe den reichstag herum und am
laufen
olic ich prophezeie heimwerker und
handwerker einer meinung sind ist ein
handwerker
jetzt haben wir hier die fugen zwischen
fließe und acryl drauf und wenn das
aktuell getroffene streichen darüber
wird immer geld wieder zeit deswegen wie
gesagt drauf machen und dann ein
bisschen trocknen lassen und damit der
farbe noch mal drüber streichen und hier
haben wir auch noch wasser zum abziehen
bundes abziehen das vordergründige
machen welt mit abziehen kennt sich der
kicker aus st
[Musik]
murat kann man schnell
was ich von maria gewusst jedoch die
hände waschen so genau deine hier oder
ist das wirklich für dich gemacht
je mehr der kindergarten küche für nicht
richtig schön es ist nicht nur ein
schönes projekt unserer stiftung sondern
es ist ja auch ein schönes soziales
miteinander denn nicht nur die küche ein
oder die partner die wir hier mit an
bord haben sondern auch die eltern die
erzieher und eben auch umliegende
geschäfte und unternehmen beteiligen
sich das heißt es kommen wirklich ganz
viele menschen legen mit hand an
unterstützenden kindergarten so dass die
kinder und erzieher dort ganz bald schon
richtig schöne küche haben alles was wir
von uns aus machen können werden wir
erledigen es gibt natürlich auch dinge
die überlassen wir den profis wie zum
beispiel strom und wasser verlegen da
sollte man auf jeden fall immer darauf
achten und es nicht selber machen
sondern wirklich den meister überlassen
[Musik]
nicht so
aber jetzt nicht so herzlich wie sich
hier
endlich mal profis am bau hier da kann
ich mehr sagen und zwar mario und
claudio kennt ja eigentlich aus den
anderen folgen sind die kanadier so
sagen teamchef
und höhere und höre genau
das haben einige beim letzten mal schon
gefragt ob die zwei immer kommen ein
bisschen viel bei über 3.000 hat und
jetzt wie gesagt die helfen uns beim
aufbau und der kindergarten küche und
eine küche aufzufallen ist eine ganz
ganz krasse arbeit also man darf das
nicht unterschätzen
das ist nein kein job für dich ging ja
auf jeden fall jetzt will ich zeigen
manchmal die küche was mir schon ein
bisschen vorbereitet haben nun die
krisen sind gelegt werden dass im
gestrichen diesen verputzt und die
elektroleitungen aufgelegt ich hoffe wir
haben alles richtig gemacht so wie es
mit der serie geplant haben und da geht
es los
so
dass ich hier es ist mir nicht ganz ganz
kleiner raum
oder
aber was machen wir dann braucht ihr so
stellen wir uns vor zwei tagen die
herausforderungen gebaut das wird alles
fast komplett angeglichen für die
erinnerung und hier komplett ausgenutzt
manchmal tragen
[Musik]
das ist jetzt die küche also schon
riesengroß die geräte von bosch die
fehlen jetzt noch aber ihr seht mal
obwohl es so ein kleiner raum ist wie
viel material ist eine richtige
materialschlacht und darauf bin ich
jetzt keine schraube fehlen keine leiste
keine rückwand es ist wirklich heftig zu
machen die kamera aus
[Musik]
aber nicht
so heilig so so ich bin sowieso ich sage
dazu freunde die dann gegen den genießen
dann sehen wir keine freunde
[Musik]
ich will ich will nicht mein knie
zusammenarbeiten
ich will dass es aufhört
warum muss ich nur mit ihm arbeiten
was habe ich das habe ich das habe ich
gemacht was habe ich gemacht warum muss
ich mit ihm arbeiten
lang kenne mich aus das kommt übrigens
aus meiner region ist sie kurz ein baum
satz lass mal lieber wirklich ist ihr
sagen nur die tür so dass ich kann es
wirklich hat er jahrelang gearbeitet
weiß es nicht aber wir wollen doch nicht
noch mehr kaputt
[Musik]
hallo da seid ihr ja schon
schön dass du da bist
ich habe mich schon gefreut habe ich
mich ja darf ich zu euch setzen
und was ist ein seit dem letzten mal
passiert die alte küche ist weg und
dann ist die neue gekommen waren da so
zwei lustige coole typen da die die
aufgebaut haben mario und claudio
ich habe auch marion mit einem claudio
gesprochen die am mac sagt dass du
klaust der kumpel von denen wirst seid
ihr jetzt beste freunde voll cool und
habt ihr die kirche schon gesehen habt
ihr also gespickt
ok du darfst du auch zuschauen okay also
ich habe heute mein ganzes auto voll
gepackt ich habe ganz viele sachen für
euch dabei und die küche kann kann ich
jetzt heute einrichten aber ich brauche
ein bisschen hilfe ja könnt ihr mir dann
helfen okay aber die küche ist ein
bisschen klein das heißt alle auf einmal
können wir nicht aber ich hole dann
immer ein paar von euch rein zum helfen
okay natürlich natürlich alle dürfen
helfen hälfte daher auch so schön mit in
der küche war super ok ich würde sagen
wir gehen jetzt alle gemeinsam rein und
machen die küche schön ja wer hat lust
dazu
also kommt
da geht mit
[Musik]
bester hier ist der friedrich box grube
und zwar der hat uns hier käufe im
kindergarten meine ganzen
wasserinstallation und es ist dein kind
geht gab ja gar nicht in den
kindergarten da geht den anderen in der
katholischen st aber es ist keine
freundschaft aber trotzdem dass du uns
der käufer strich saumäßig kunden sagt
ja und was waren intention dahinter
einfach weil wir dem anderen
kindergarten auch relativ viel helfen
und deswegen haben wir auch mal gesagt
wer sind diese menschen die aus
rockenhausen mit nicht cool die sich
dann gegenseitig unterstützen und hier
helfen es mich wahnsinnig allerdings
haben wir machen auch alle die viel
zusammen wir haben jetzt letzten freitag
wieder 900 euro gesammelt für die kinder
war für flüchtlinge aus lycra ihn
ja und hier ist genau ausgleich wir
haben auch viele unternehmen geholfen
aus der region nobilia oder blanco oder
wie sie alle heißen und du jetzt auch
mit dabei 1000 bank noch mal superman
schrieb ich klasse
[Musik]
jetzt dicke hier fertig claudia und
maria hab da echt schön aufgebaut ja
wirklich mühe allemal oben wahnsinn ja
es ist nicht schön glaublich ich finde
es völlig von der rolle
waren hier im kindergarten waren viele
kinder das war müsste ich ja alles ist
nass der lustigsten
der lustigste war der kleine klaus gern
wären bestimmt dann habe ich noch heute
noch gar nicht gesehen muss der heute ja
ich habe ihn schon gesehen ja er hat
lauteste kurzem wurden
sprechen
heute auch ella mit dabei das heißt eure
arbeit hier ist eigentlich getan oder
super und wir haben absichtlich jetzt
keine holzelemente bestellt diese
einteiler das heißt morath die ganzen
schubladen sind noch leer vielleicht
kannst du dich darum kümmern denn wir
haben diese holz einteiler ihr wisst ja
eine küche ist immer dann gut wenn sehr
außen schönes aber innen auch gut
organisiert ist deswegen hatte murat
dennoch los denn hier in rockenhausen
jetzt das holzwerk und da kannst du
nämlich direkt der ganz in holz einen
teil erholen und ich kann so lange hier
schonmal auspacken noch mal kurz zu den
kids gehen und alle haben wir auch heute
mitarbeiter hilft uns auch mit und dann
werde ich schon mal die ganzen kinder
dazu holen denn die dürfen heute helfen
und die küche einrichten durchgehend das
holzwerk ist ja okay du hast dich zu den
kindern ist gleich ein super puma
wie hilfreich war der murat hier bei der
ganzen sache hat
er euch auch wenn das gerade von eins
bis zehn wie sehr war ja ich bin noch da
ich kann euch noch hören ok übrigens
wird die nächste küche die wir gemeinsam
planen die community küche das heißt
beim nächsten mal werden wir uns sehen
sind wir bei einem zuschauer zu hause
und wenn ihr mitmachen möchte dann könnt
ihr euch gerne bewerben auf kitchen de
dürfte gerne ein handy video einfach
hochladen vielleicht noch ein paar fotos
einen kleinen text dazu und wir werden
uns dann alle bewerbungen anschauen ihr
bekommt auch eine bestätigungs-e-mail
und dann bin ich schon gespannt drauf
denn dann die nächste küche die
community küche für euch und einer von
euch wird dann dieser küche gewinnen und
ich bin schon sehr gespannt darauf wo
wir dann hinkommen werden welche familie
kennenlernen werden oder welche single
muss ja nicht unbedingt eine familie
sein und ja da freue ich mich schon
richtig drauf das wird dann noch mal
richtig aufregend
kann ich dann wieder mit euch rechnen
sehr gut dann wollte ich jetzt mal die
kinder und die einrichtung ich hab
nämlich ganze auto voll geladen
wir sind hier immer noch in rockenhausen
und zwar im holzwerk rockenhausen das
gehört zu der kesseböhmer gruppe und das
hier ist eine holzmanufaktur und zwar
hier machen sie die besteck einsätze für
küchen und es ist eine manufaktur es ist
wirklich krasse handarbeit ihr wisst es
gibt besteck einsätze das sind diese
einsätze wohin küchentrend aus metall
oder aus holz und am hochwertigsten die
aus holz da ist eine menge handarbeit
dabei und ich war schon ein paar monaten
hier und ich weiß die werden wir diese
besteck einsätze jetzt für uns
herstellen oder ich mal rein und zeigt
euch wie viel arbeit hinter solchen
simplen für euch vielleicht simple
besteck einsätze wie viel arbeit darin
steckt
wir sind hier in der westpfalz und wie
gesagt woran erkennt man das ist eine
firma ist das merkt man eigentlich
sofort als schwabe wenn sie kennen das
heißt hier ist alles sauber hielt als
blitzeblank ich gehe jetzt rein irgendwo
da drin war der martin auf mich und dann
geht es los und da gehen wir die
manufaktur
gleichzeitig üben abrichten okay das ist
gerade für mich okay
[Musik]
nach der grundierung kommen die teile
noch einmal für 15 minuten in den ofen
und was auch ganz ganz wichtig ist wenn
man über das thema nachhaltigkeit
spricht und zwar alles wird ja auch
diese auf dieses förderband lackiert
oder drauf geworfen da kommt eine rakel
und macht die ganze farbe den lack weg
und dann wird es komplett
wiederverwertet und nachher in dem eimer
gesammelt komplett neuen in viskosität
rein gemacht und dann wieder mit dem
gleichen material wieder lackiert also
so richtig nachhaltig aber jetzt gehen
mal hinter den ofen da waren die man auf
uns und zwar hoch ist oder
so leicht war aber jetzt haben wir die
grundierung drauf und jetzt kommt noch
mal inzwischen schliff das ist übrigens
der zweite schon und der wirt kommt
nicht auch wieder per hand gemacht wenn
dafür gibt es keine maschine und da geht
mir ganz großen
[Musik]
so jetzt kommt noch einmal die letzte
ölung sozusagen danach kommt jetzt traum
dann geht es noch mal durch den
trockenen rufen und dann ist unser
produkt fertig und ich bringe alles in
den kindergarten
[Musik]
jetzt sind meine neben besteck einsetzte
verliebt und tausend dank nochmal marken
verdacht sie uns im kindergarten helfen
bürgern man ist ja auch selber von hier
genau wir sind hier und fühlen uns in
der region verbunden und da ist das
selbstverständlich und für mich war es
einfach wichtig dass ihr einige für euch
leicht ein simples produkte gar keine
gedanken macht das jemals sehen wie die
menschen dahinter steckt viel arbeit wie
viel fleiß der hand und halt so dann
nehme ich jetzt nicht und da gibt
ok zu sein
danke schön machen wie lang ein
gerade kleine küchen sollten wirklich
gut organisiert sein damit man den
überblick behält und wirklich auch alles
rein bekommt ich weiß viele denken sie
jetzt vielleicht wieso soll ich jetzt
küchen zonen definieren wenn ich nur
drei für schränke habe aber gerade dann
ist es wichtig damit er wirklich auch
alles gut verstauen können und eben auch
alles da habt wo es braucht ich weiß
dass viele küchen so klein sind dass man
sich quasi nur umdrehen bauch und
wirklich von der einen küchen zone schon
in der anderen steht aber dann ist es
wichtig ihr behaltet immer den perfekten
überblick krisenzonen bedeutet überlegt
euch am besten vorher was habt ihr an
verstauung gut was habt ihr an
lebensmitteln was habt ihr ein werkzeug
und was an hilfsmitteln und dann könnt
ihr euch die küchen zonen zum beispiel
auf post-its notieren und daneben
dementsprechend planen ich bin immer
ganz gut wenn man dazu erst mal seine
papier planung macht oder auch gerne in
der digital planung das heißt schreibt
euch gerne mal auf wo ihr welche
schränkt gehabt und dann könnt ihr euer
stau gut eben schön verplanen ich mache
jetzt so dass ich zum einen die zone
spülen müll und wasser platz habe das
heißt dort kommt alles hin was wirklich
zum bereich abspülen gehört geschirr
einigen spülmaschine oder eben auch müll
und organisations platz die zweite
küchen zone ist die vorbereitungs zone
da sind zum beispiel sachen wie messer
und schneidebretter rührschüssel oder
citrus pressen und gewürze eben
gegenstände und vor allem werkzeuge die
ihr zum vorbereiten von lebensmitteln
benötigt die dritte krisenzone ist die
bevorratung das heißt da kommen eure
lebensmittelvorräte rein denn in vielen
haushalten ist es ja auch so dass es
keinen extra vorratsraum gibt sondern
wirklich in der küche direkt bevorratet
werden muss und da sollte man vor allem
immer den überblick behalten damit eben
auch keine lebensmittel vergessen und
dann eben auch weggeschmissen werden
es gibt dann noch eine küchen zone
kochen und dort kommt natürlich alles
hin was ihr direkt an der herdplatte
braucht das heißt kochtöpfe werkzeuge
oder eben auch gewisse zutaten die ihr
während des kaufvorgangs mit integrieren
wollte
die kirchen solbakken beinhaltet
natürlich alles wie das wort schon sagt
alles was ihr zum backen braucht das
heißt alle werkzeuge küchengeräte oder
auch lebensmittel und bestimmte
werkzeuge die ihr zum backen und
vorbereiten zum backen benötigt dann
gibt es noch die kirchen so ne
aufbewahren und da meine ich alles was
praktisch lebensmittel zum beispiel aus
bewahren soll sowas wie vorratsbehälter
oder auch fest paar dosen und dann gibt
es noch die küchen zone anrichten und
versteckt und das beinhaltet alles was
ihr später zum servieren eurer gerichte
braucht stellen dass wir noch dran seid
ich möchte ganz kurz unterbrechen es
geht gleich mit kutschen weiter aber
soll auch heute wieder ein ganz ganz
tolles gewinnspiele geben und zwar gibt
es diesmal zu gewinnen unsere neuen brot
formen dibaba formen die gibt es jetzt
seit kurzem bei uns und zwar ist es
nicht nur eine plattform sondern
wirklich eine schöne backform die ihr
auf jeder herd auch induktion gasgrill
backofen überall benutzen könnt und eben
brote backen könnt kasten kuchen nuss
zöpfe lotus zopf oder zum beispiel auch
aufläufe oder kattas und ihr könnt eine
von diesen bot backformen gewinnen wenn
ihr mir gerne in die kommentare schreibt
was ihr darin als erstes zubereiten
möchte und ihr seht ihr alle unsere
farben die wir bisher haben und jeder
tropfen hinein x verlost deswegen
schreibt gerne darunter und die gewinner
werden dann per los natürlich gezogen
und ich würde sagen jetzt machen wir
noch eine ganz kurze werbeunterbrechung
und dann geht es gleich weiter mit pimp
my kitchen teil 3
[Applaus]
[Musik]
jetzt ist die küche fertig und kann
eingeräumt werden und da legen wir euch
am besten diese küchen so wie wir
anfangs definiert haben schreibt ja auch
post-its zum beispiel und könnt dann
alles erstmal ankleben das heißt ihr
überlegt jetzt schon wo was hinkommt und
dann ist es beim einräumen einfacher
damit ist man doch nicht überfordert man
hat einen plan und ich habs jetzt auch
so gemacht dass ich draußen schon im
kindergarten flur einfach alles
ausgebreitet habe und sortiert haben
einzelne kisten macht man beim umzug
übrigens auch so und dann kann man jetzt
abschnitt für abschnitt alessandro
spülen öl und wasser platz
es war einfach
[Musik]
nachdem jetzt die einzelnen bereiche in
der küche definiert wurden kann ich
schon mal anfangen und die küche schön
einräumen
also das wichtigste in der kindergarten
küche ist denke ich auch mitunter dass
die putzmittel nicht in kinder
reichweite verstaut werden vorher war da
ja auch im schrank zum abschließen und
die habe ich mir gedacht packe ich die
kurz mittel einfach ganz nach oben da
kommen auch keine kinder dran alles ist
sicher verstaut hier das sind so die
vorräte und hier kommen die kinder auch
nicht dran hier würde ich jetzt einfach
mal so der allzweckreiniger mit
reinpacken da habe ich natürlich auch
wieder unico puro mitgebracht von
unseren freunden vom markt und von
alessandra da mische ich jetzt auch
direkt einfach mal ein reiniger an uns
konzentrat kommt dann auch nach oben und
dann kann ich erzähle dir einiger die
putztücher da oben die putzmittel und
dann ist alles sicher verstaut
bis dahin das konzentrat einfüllen und
dann mit wasser auffüllen
[Musik]
okay kommt ihr zweimal reli und lucy
wollt ihr mir helfen die back schublade
einzuräumen naja guck mal das machen wir
hier rein und zwar dieses lochmuster das
ist total cool wenn man da diese
einteiler einstecken kann und dann wird
nichts mehr durcheinander hier in der
küche da kommt kein chaos rein okay ja
so wird es machen
darfst du guck mal dass eine bank martha
holtmann dann teig aus kohls darfst du
dir mal rein legen da genau jetzt messen
wir mal ab ich nehme den schweren großen
auswahl starb das legen wir den mal
drauf und das handstück gerät nebendran
super und damit es hier nicht verrutscht
warum aber auch so eine leistung fertig
die los hier nimmt die große los sie
vielleicht kannst du dir da reinstellen
ja ihr habt mir vielleicht hast du hier
rein wenn das jetzt probiere mal
hahn super
und meinst du vielleicht heli das dass
da auch noch reinpasst das runde ins
eckige kriegen wir uns da rein
super
und vielleicht kann es schaffen
die aussteller hier und vielleicht
kannst du diesen einteiler hier an
machen
das cool aus
wir zeigen die back schublade gefällt
ihr euch tolle machen wir die mal zu
das hat unser freund der norbert
geschenkt für den kindergarten
vielleicht könnt ihr immer ganz begrüßen
[Musik]
ihr seid keine haushalts küche deswegen
werde ich jetzt gewürze einfach
einräumen die bereits in gläsern sind
denn ich glaube im kindergarten macht
jetzt keiner die mühe und füllt dann
immer gewürze auf das heißt alle gewürze
die ich jetzt hier gekauft ob sind im
schönen gläsern die sind ja auch schön
verpackt und die kann man ja alle
verschließen und deswegen mag ich die
hier oben rein da ist nämlich einen
dunstabzug schön versteckt und hier oben
ist noch viel platz und das heißt hier
und mit schönem ausfallschutz da kann
dann auch nichts runter fallen
[Musik]
das thema dekoration ist ja auch in
einer kleinen küche ganz wichtig damit
man sich trotzdem wohnlich fühlt in der
küche aber wenn man nicht so viel platz
hat sollte man schauen dass die deko
möglichst funktional ist deswegen habe
ich hier in der küche auch dieses
aufsatz regal von mobiliar mit
eingeplant zum einen ist es einfach
schön dekorativ zum anderen bringt es
noch mal so ein licht ambiente mit in
die küche weil es einfach hier
beleuchtet ist und ich habe aber auch
einen schönen stauraum das heißt alles
was ich jetzt hier drauf platziere sieht
man das bringt die diese wohnlichkeit
und die werbe mit rein und ich kann hier
zum beispiel kräuter platzieren
diese einsätze
die gebe ich jetzt morath und elan nach
draußen da können sie nämlich schön
kräuter anpflanzen und ich kann hier den
rest dekorieren und auch hier oben die
fensterbank weil das fenster da oben
sowieso nicht benutzt wird also es wird
nicht geöffnet das heißt da habe ich
schon licht und wünschen eine fläche her
da kommt sonne rein und jetzt nicht
so mit der iaea zusammen pflanzen wir
dass kräuter regal grad für die küche
und
ganz ganz wichtig und ein bisschen
granulat rein weil granulat speichern
die feuchtigkeit lockert die erde auf
und
ella jetzt aber unten bisschen granulat
rein gemacht und jetzt machen wir
folgendes das weißt du auch schon hin
was ist das petersilie das sind glatte
petersilie wie machst du dir ein
zeitweise schon geht ein bisschen
auflockern geld den ball genau ein
bisschen auf reisen schön rein genau
genau jetzt rein machen genau und neben
der peter sie gebissen als begleit kraut
weil der schütze die petersilie rosmarin
weil rosmarin des mögen zb die ganzen
blattläuse und alle die ganzen lösen
tiere die es gibt die mögen kein ruß
machen wenn rosmarin so ein bisschen
stinkig mal
ganz gut ja okay machen auch ein
bisschen den ballen müssen auseinander
und und ist dann nebendran pflanzen
richtig so ein bisschen luft dazwischen
lassen und jetzt können noch ein
bisschen erde braucht tun und wenn man
die erde drauf getan haben kann man hier
die erde hier genau so kommt rein genau
um ein bisschen erde dazwischen
jawohl jetzt ein bisschen andrücken
genau jetzt noch ein bisschen granulat
und machen es auf die oberfläche und das
ist granulat sorgt auch dafür dass die
eher links so schnell austrocknet genau
und wenn man das jetzt immer schön ab
erntet wächst das wochenlang nach da ist
ganz ganz bitter weil ich dafür hat und
es liegt haben wir ja durch das ganze
regalsystemen jetzt haben wir hier noch
den die minze
gericht aber richtig gut wow erwartet
trotz der papa hat und noch kein
bisschen erde auffüllen so das bringt
jetzt alle in die küche und ganz ganz
wichtig ist es hier nicht zu viel gießen
aber auch nicht zu wenig wobei 90 fall
ist dass die menschen zu viel gießen und
ganz wichtig ist natürlich auch das
licht aber das haben wir ja das regal
das regalsystem weil da ist extra eine
kleine kräuter beleuchtung und den
pflanzen beleuchtung drin was die
pflanzen zum wachstum bringt auch wenn
man eine küche ein bisschen weniger
licht hat
während murat und lh draußen die
pflanzen einpflanzen kümmere ich mich
jetzt schon mal um die dekoration der
küche
[Musik]
solche küchenkräuter halten immer extrem
gut wenn ihr sie in die kräutertöpfe
gibt von gv und zwar einfach mit dem
topf einsetzen
hier ist ein stil den hier reinstecken
so fixiert man praktisch den pflanztopf
mit dem kräuter tropf und hier ist eine
schnur und die zieht dann das wasser
nach oben so viel wasser wie die pflanze
eben benötigt das heißt hier einmal
wasser auffüllen da muss man es auch
nicht gießen
[Musik]
hier ist noch so ein wasserstands besser
drin und er zeigt immer an wie folgt das
wasser noch ist
[Musik]
danke schön war das haupt aber toll
eingepflanzt weißt was du setzt dich
dort riecht gleich richtig gut hier
[Musik]
richtig spaghetti bolognese hat es auch
irgendwie eine besondere wirkung
es schützt vor bösen tieren okay
[Musik]
okay wir stellen nicht
ohne sellerie ohne mich
meine energie kommt daher
jetzt die küche fertig und ich zeige
euch jetzt mal hier die highlights in
der küche jetzt präsentiere ich euch die
fertige kindergarten küche die kirche
habe ich für mich und teilweise tiefen
geküsst gestaltet so dass ich den
geringen raum in der küche optimal
nutzen kann und ich habe hier ein helles
alpinweiß mit einem mineral grün
kombiniert um die küche farblich einfach
richtig schön zu gestalten damit sie
nicht zu klein aussieht habe ich ein
wunderschönes stollen regal dazu
kombiniert und dieses bekommt ihr
übrigens direkt bei nobilia weil eben
immer so viele nach dem regal fragen das
steuer regal gibt's übrigens boden tief
so habe ich zum beispiel damals in eco
und sarahs küche eingebaut und eben auch
als aufsatz regal so wie jetzt hier in
der küche für die arbeitsplatte und ich
finde es toll regal gibt der küche
einfach ein wunderschönes wohnliches
ambiente und hat ein schönes elegantes
design
dort kann man vor allem stauraum optimal
und dekorativ nutzen und man kann sogar
pflanzen integrieren und es hat sogar
eine pflanzenwachstums lampe und der
große vorteil ist dass sich die
einzelnen elemente die teilweise auch
aus holz bestehen eben miteinander
kombinieren lassen und ich habe jetzt
hier das regal dekorativ mit pflanzen
bestückt die beim kochen und backen eben
zum einsatz kommen können und auch
tassen und vasen integriert und deswegen
habe ich mich hier für den norweger easy
touch front in mineral können und
alpinweiß ultramat entschieden weil sie
einfach länger sauber bleibt so dass man
sich keine gedanken mehr um
fingerabdrücke in der küche machen muss
weil sie eben eine innovative
oberflächenbeschichtung hat die die
fläche versiegelt so dass er länger
sauber bleibt und eben sich ganz einfach
reinigen lässt
die arbeitsplatte in der küche ist aus
einem ganz besonderen material das ist
nämlich eine extra arbeitsplatte und die
hat so eine richtig schöne 3d oberfläche
und sieht wirklich aus wären naturstein
ist aber viel viel kostengünstiger als
der natur stellen und zwar hat sie eine
besonders starke beschichtung zu dass
sie katz und quell unempfindlich ist und
genau deswegen ist sie auch für den
kindergarten oder auch für stark
beanspruchte küchen bestens geeignet
an der rechten küchenzeile habe ich dann
einen kleinen und großen apotheker
schrank von kesseböhmer integriert so
dass lebensmittel oder eben auch
geschirr aufgeräumt werden können und so
kommt man dann auch von beiden seiten an
das eingeräumte dran und wir weit stets
den überblick das heißt lebensmittel
werden hier einfach nicht mehr vergessen
und vor allem können hier auch
lebensmittel im kindergarten und
utensilien in augenhöhe der kinder aus
bewahrt werden wenn sie zum beispiel
eben beim frühstück machen mithelfen
sollen und lebensmittel oder auch
putzzeug oder andere gegenstände anti
die kinder nicht dran kommen sollen die
können wir ganz gut oben verstaut werden
und man hat sie trotzdem stets im blick
dem apotheker schrank findet ihr
übrigens auch einzelne tablette und
zubehörteile die ihr dann wiederum
individuell untereinander kombinieren
und austauschen können in der küche habe
ich zwei wasser plätze integriert zum
einen wegen den auflagen das heißt ein
wasser platz ist praktisch ein
handwaschbecken und ein wasser platz ist
die spüle einheit die eben auch aus
küchenarmaturen becken unter
unterschrank organisation besteht und
die ist dann eben dafür da dass man dort
geschirrspülen kann oder eben auch
lebensmittel reinigen kann und ich habe
mich jetzt hier für eine kompakte ein
becken spiele entschieden da die eben
auch für kleine küchen geeignet ist sie
ist richtig klein und praktisch und hat
trotzdem ein komfortables xl becken und
vor allem hat sie eine ganz tolle
innovation
nämlich eine erweiterbare abtropffläche
durch das verschiebbare topf gitter aus
edelstahl das heißt ihr könnt da die
abtropffläche einfach vergrößern indem
wir das edelstahl gitter einfach zur
seite schiebt die armatur sieht auch
richtig stylisch aus die hat nämlich
einen flexiblen gummischlauch in schwarz
und bietet daher einen optimalen
bewegungsradius so dass man überall im
großen becken auch eben ab draußen kann
der platz oder der spüle ist auch immer
sehr wichtig da die komplette stauraum
nutzung eben besonders in kleinen küchen
wichtig ist und hier für die mülleimer
gibt es einfach flexibler einer
kombinationen so dass man die
abfalltrennung auch für jede ortschaft
individuell einplanen kann außerdem gibt
es eine zwischenebene mit flexibleren
universal boxen und die wiederum
erleichtern das organisieren der spüle
die küchen nische habe ich mit einem
hübschen ornament dekoriert und dort
habe ich diese musik schiene integriert
das ist ein vielseitiges trainingssystem
und das bietet den vorteil dass einzelne
elemente immer wieder verschoben und
ausgetauscht werden können ohne dass man
eben ständig bohren muss das heißt wenn
die schienen einmal angebaut sind kann
man die küche nische immer wieder nach
bedarf umgestalten und eben um räumen
weil die einzelnen elemente eben
verschiebbare auf der anderen seite habe
ich ihnen denn hängeschränken den hof
integriert damit eben auch kleinere
personen an die oberen regale kommen
heim hof ist nämlich eine ganz tolle
technologie da kann man den kompletten
schrank inhalt mit einer bewegung nach
unten ziehen und kann während das
arbeiten sollte alles ohne stehen lassen
und dann ganz einfach wieder oben
verstauen alle holzelemente die ihr hier
in der küche seht also sowohl die auf
dem stollen regal als auch in den
schubladen für die ihnen einteilung
kommen direkt vom holzweg in
vockenhausen und zwei holzwerk dort ein
spezialist wenn es um massivholz
produkte geht gerade wenn es um
schubkästen oder auszüge geht und da
kann man eben die küche richtig schön
individuell gestalten und vor allem
optimal organisieren um dann genügend
platz für frische und gesunde
lebensmittel zu haben habe ich eine
große kühl und gefrierkombination von
bosch integriert und die bietet extra
viel platz für obst und gemüse weil die
küche ja wir wissen platz technisch sehr
begrenzt ist habe ich hier in der tiefen
gekürzten arbeitsfläche domino felder in
die kurve so eingebaut und diese dann
einfach umgedreht so dass ich wirklich
extrem viel platz war hier habe ich noch
den speziellen backofen der mit der
reinigung pyrolyse und home connect
ausgestattet ist so dass man den
backofen ganz einfach mit meiner rezepte
app kombinieren kann und so können die
erzieher und auch die kinder rezepte in
meiner app auswählen und die
einstellungen direkt an den ofen senden
das heißt man muss hart temperaturen
bugs edgar nicht mehr separat am ofen
einstellen ich finde die küche ergibt
immer ein gesamtbild wenn also freunden
und arbeitsplatten gut harmonieren und
die küche dann noch mit einer tollen
rückwand und vor allem einer indirekten
beleuchtung ausgestattet ist dann macht
sie echt schon ein richtiger fan und
gerade die vitrine beleuchtung und die
indirekte sockel beleuchtung finde ich
bringt die küche echt optisch zum
schweben und ich finde sie macht sie
dadurch echte gleich viel hochwertiger
und vor allem erscheint sie viel
eleganter und sorgt vor allem für eine
wohnliche atmosphäre und das tor einen
kindergarten da wir haben hier aus
diesem kleinen raum echt viel rausgeholt
und mir gefällt die küche ziemlich gut
jetzt bin ich mal gespannt darauf ob sie
an und natürlich auch den anderen
erzählen und kindern auch gut gefällt
ich würde mal sagen wir wollen jetzt
einfach mal die alle rein denn darum ist
wirklich sehr sehr klein und dann darf
sie sich erst mal umschauen und die
kinder und die erzieher dann noch später
anna dicke hier ist fertig
[Musik]
ja nicht hier habt ihr diese mosaiken
leiste das heißt da gibt es einfach
elemente die könnt ihr reinklicken und
wegklicken das heißt wenn euch das ist
eine nicht zu sagen oder erstellen
wollte einfach herum organisieren genau
und habe ich so eine halterung
eigentlich ist es eine ipad halterung
das weiß nicht ob ihr ipad in der küche
benutzer im kindergarten fall fliegen
von jahr könnte das gern machen aber ich
dachte es auch ganz cool für kochbücher
denn ihr könnt die da auch ganz gut
aufschlagen und drauflegen und dann
wirklich auch euch zu drehen das heißt
wenn ihr hier kocht und habt ihr einfach
das buch aufnehmen die höhe gern einigen
immer alles sehen wollen da kann man
schon rein schauen oder auch mal ein
handy und video abzuspielen
und dann können wir es gern wieder
einfach an platz zurück
[Musik]
dass es so euer kaffee und tee schrank
und weil er die schränke wenn man
versucht den platz bis ganz nach oben
auszunutzen aber ist denen nicht alle in
groß deswegen habt ihr da ein eigenlob
drin von kirsten willmann du kannst man
den griff einfach ziehen genau hier
unten einfach runter und du kannst sogar
bis unten und das festhalten
genau und dann haben wir also tiefen
gekürzte arbeitsflächen das heißt dass
man hier einfach nicht so eng steht weil
hätten wir eine normale 60er tiefe dann
kann man sich eigentlich gar nicht mehr
bewegen und deswegen habe das hier so
tiefen gekürzt und 13 kochfelder hindi
umgedreht dass man praktisch trotzdem 4
koch flächen hat aber eben das ganze
nicht so ja nicht so platz
aufbrauchen
[Musik]
vom hygiene am wald die auflage ihr
braucht zwei waschbecken und seid ihr
einst für die hände der name jetzt dahin
gepackt genau
und dann sind wir eigentlich auf der
seite ein waschbecken habt ihr hier und
da ist einfach einfach auf alles schön
organisiert das heißt nur ein mal hier
unten drunter
[Musik]
und die habe ich jetzt mal eure
lebensmittelvorräte reingepackt
und dachte einfach so unten die schweren
sachen und die vorräte und die
geöffneten sachen sind dann hier oben
auf augenhöhe dann platzt irgendwann das
klein
[Musik]
mir gefällt die kirche ich bin wirklich
total beeindruckt war sie aus dem
kleinen raum herausgeholt habe
doch nach stauraum ist und sowohl für
die kinder an alles gedacht ist als auch
für die erzieher dass wir doch unseren
tenor unterstellen können im café koch
können nein absolut nicht auf jeden fall
gespannt auf die reaktion der kollegen
entdecken und ja dann würde ich sagen
ist die küche jetzt offiziell gepimpt
und was gehört bei für mein kitchen
immer dazu die kamera heute brauchen da
wir machen noch kurzen bild zusammen ja
okay jetzt
hat annette küche schon gesehen und fand
sehr richtig richtig schön und jetzt bin
ich schon gespannt darauf was morath und
die anderen kids von der kirche halten
du musst nicht wann wir wissen nicht bei
rtl2 alles noch
einmal wissen nicht wo er ist halt zwei
achtung ich mache jetzt auf und da bin
ich gespannt was du von der neuen küche
heißt ok und du musst mir jetzt schon
was versprechen dass du dich um die
küche kümmern wirst okay ich bin kein
tag ja nein ach du bist du bist
feuerwehrmann dh wenn irgendwas in der
küche in pasching auf ok
lacht nein nein du bist der beste mann
wo ich kenne ok also jetzt
deine neue
küche
und
müsli und alles gemalt und kennst du die
person hier ja er ist das kennt schließt
er liegt ja die war gestern
und das ist jetzt eine neue küche und du
musst mir echt aufpassen dass hier
keiner was kaputt macht okay da kannst
du hier kochen und backen macht was du
möchtest
jetzt zieh mal das runter
und weiter und weiter
so
cool oder
machst das jetzt jeden tag
ja weil da ist sicher carla drin haha
machen wir auch was ist hier drin
geschirr ok
ja
eure neue
küche
wo man gefäß ihr euch wissen noch wie
die alte ausgesehen hat wisst ihr dass
nach
ok wo jetzt wollt ihr mal die neue küche
sehen zumal die schränke aufmachen und
alle
genau das will ich bin ich richtig
glücklich denn die küche kam wirklich
sehr sehr gut bei den kindern und auch
bei den erzieherinnen an und es macht
mich einfach nur glücklich dass sie dort
jetzt jeden tag kochen und backen können
und vor allem auch ein gesundes leckeres
frühstück gemeinsam mit den kindern
zubereiten können ihr könnt mir ja gerne
mal in die kommentare schreiben wie euch
die küche gefällt und ob wir euch die
ein oder anderen tipps wollen wir wieder
abholen konnte ich hoffe ich konnte euch
jetzt wieder bisschen helfen teure küche
zu hause gut zu organisieren und vor
allem vielleicht habt ihr euch ja auch
ein paar deko tipps abholen können denn
ich finde auch eine küche die auch schön
aufgeräumt ist kann auch schön dekoriert
sein denkt auf jeden fall anders
gewinnspiel das heißt macht ganz gerne
mit bei unserer kitchen community küche
auf kitchen de findet ihr noch mal alle
infos ich freue mich jetzt schon auf
alle bewerbungen ich bin jetzt schon
gespannt wie eure jetzigen küchen
aussehen und vor allem freue ich mich
drauf jemanden von euch kennen zu lernen
und euch eine richtig schöne küche
planen zu dürfen also macht gut teilt
gern unser video und bis zum nächsten
mal
[Musik]
die lasten
seien die heutigen 1
[Musik]
ich bin da gerät der gerät wird nie müde
der gerät schlägt die ein gerät ist
immer vor dem chef im geschäft und so
hat er die gesamte spitze
hallo
[Musik]
diese sind das
nicht schön wir haben jetzt nicht
gemacht ich habe glück nicht mal gemacht
na ja klar zu den letzten griffen
gemacht habe dass auf kamera
[Gelächter]
was die landung in könntest du bist mehr
wenn die möglichkeit haben finde ich da
und genügend legen ist
gute noten
[Musik]
ich finde die aber wendet sich schon
komisch
man kann schließt alles mit ton
aufnehmen die sich das selten dass man
bei ihm auch die dummheit wird was wir
tun darunter sollten lieber lassen
willkommen so schafft er ganz ehrlich
als billigheimer dass
die highlights der küche
[Musik]
funktioniert ohne nehme ich brauche dich
und du hättest einfach den sellerie
[Musik]
das fahrzeug überfahren